well let's face it we don't always have
a lot of time to get dinner on the table
especially considering healthier gourmet
meals usually take a little more time
but that's not an issue for today
registered dietitian Abby sharp is here
with some ideas that will have you
feasting in a flash welcome thank you
thank you so much there's a bit of a
misconception that we should not be
using the microwave I know I've been
told that a couple of times but is that
really the case well not necessarily I
really think that today especially with
this new Panasonic cyclonic microwave
technology in the past we maybe have
used microwaves for rewarming meals or
trying to make meals from scratch and
the problem is the older technology
delivers the microwaves the energy level
in a kind of a linear fashion okay
this new cyclonic inverter technology
the dishes out energy in this cyclonic
kind of 3d spinning waves of power so
you can ensure your food actually cooks
evenly and consistently every single
time okay so what are we making today
we're not gonna do my tropical fruit
crisp so this is perfect for those days
when unexpected guests drop by and you
got to whip something up on the fly so
I've got a combination of some of my
favorite tropical fruits banana mango
pineapple nice little touch of butter
you can do this individual sized
portions which is what I'm doing here
but of course if you want to make a
bigger one as well this is quite big
enough to get a nice sized portion nice
is that brown sugar
Dyess coconut sugar a little lower in
the glycemic index oh I love that a
little pinch of nutmeg a little bit of
cinnamon and let's get some lime zest
quickly in there I like that yes I love
that a little bit of zest in there mix
that up until it gets nice and coated
and into a dish here microwave safe
microwave-safe I mean you just want to
put any like metals or anything I got so
put this on top there we go just a bit
of granola exactly I just kind of mixed
up some of the similar ingredients we've
got some coconut some rolled oats some
that coconut sugar just a touch of
butter nice and this is going in for two
and a half minutes on high and I
this has got the electrostatic glass
contentment touch control panel so you
can swipe up you can swipe down you can
kind of add your x thing with your
smartphone kind of technology I'm just
gonna add two and a half minutes let
that start going and not only can you
make amazing desserts because I love
dessert you can also make amazing meals
from scratch so for example this is my
quinoa kale risotto which I've got going
on there which is I made that using the
genius sensor function and this is
unique to the cyclonic because what it
does is it has 20 different healthy
foods already programmed into the
microwave things like quinoa oatmeal
soup potatoes rice and it will sense the
amount of moisture in that food and
they'll automatically adjust the cooking
time so it takes that guesswork out of
it for you and it'll and it'll figure
out exactly how long to cook up lovely I
couldn't help but notice these a very
colorful looking dishes here ok nice so
we've got some root vegetable chips I
bet you've never made chips in the
microwave for one thing right not free
cuz I don't have to add any oil to it so
basically all I've done is I've sliced
some of these nice root vegetables on a
little mandolin them onto a microwavable
safe dish again with a little bit of
parchment paper and I'm just gonna see
some mine up with some chili powder oh I
like that you know you can get get
creative with the flavor profile as well
a little bit a little bit more of that
gorgeous lime zest
these look like beets to me a salad is
carrots I sometimes do sweet potato as
well you can kind of play with that as
well but it's nice to get that fiber in
you like you're getting a little bit of
a treat so when that comes out of course
if we want to pop those in but they go
for 30 seconds on high flip them over in
other words and you can finish them one
or two more times as well but you can
see right there they're crispy they're
light that great alternative of course
to the fried potato chips that we know
we know we know them them so well yes we
love them but this would be an
alternative so from you know weekend
entertaining like the risotto to those
weekend weeknight favorites like I've
got some pulled chicken sliders here
nice it's so easy to actually prepare
meals from scratch now yes because of
that cyclonic converter technology very
good well where can people find out more
about the res
as you've talked about today Lee so you
can go to Panasonic comm lots of
inspiration there for coming up with
your own microwavable safe recipes as
well very good we'll post a link to that
on our website Kitchener dot ctv news
dot CA i think it still has a couple
seconds you can we show this sure let's
see what's coming on
that's just joy not to burn ourselves
here very careful yes forgot that towel
there we go looks good lovely and great
to have on a day like today we will take
another look at your weather for the
rest of the day coming up as well